[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es eines
meiner lieblings cupcake rezepte denn
wir machen heute posten prim cupcakes
eigentlich ist es ein klassiker der hier
neu definiert wurde denn ihr kennt
sicherlich alle den boston bruins
der ist in den usa total beliebt und
besteht aus zwei lagen kuchenteig einer
vanillecreme füllung und einem
schokoladenüberzug das ganze habt ihr
hier als cupcake variante und ich bin
total verliebt und mache sie seit jahren
genauso für die leckere posten cream
benötigen wir milch außerdem ein gelb
etwas zucker ein wenig speisestärke ganz
wichtig ist auch vanille zucker oder
vanille extrakt und eine prise salz
wir geben nun alle zutaten bis auf die
milch in eine schüssel ich starte mit
eigelb zucker vanillezucker und der
prise salz und verrührt das gut
[Musik]
nachdem sich alles gut miteinander
verbunden hat kommt die speisestärke mit
hinzu und wird klümpchen frei eingerührt
[Musik]
nachdem diese vorbereitung getroffen
wurde geben wir das ganze an die seite
und machen weiter am herd mit der milch
in einem kochtopf wird die milch nun
erhitzt und zwar so lange bis sie kurz
vorm aufsteigen ist das heißt man sich
kleine bläschen bilden dann könnt ihr
das ganze schon vom herd nehmen und ich
rühre dabei auch immer ständig um damit
mir auch der topfboden nicht anbrennt
[Musik]
damit wir die temperatur ausgleichen
können und damit sich dann alles
miteinander vereint geben wir jetzt
schluck für schluck die milch in die cap
masse und rühren dabei ständig um
[Musik]
sobald ihr dann die komplette milch
unter ständigem rühren in die aigcp
masse gegeben habt kommt das ganze auch
schon wieder zurück in den topf auf den
herd habe ich die zwischenzeit
ausgeschaltet es sollte die auch tun
damit euch dann nichts anbrennt
[Musik]
und nun schalten wir den herd auch schon
wieder an und lassen das ganze unter
ständigem rühren einmal aufkochen und
eindecken
[Musik]
nach dem aufkochen ist die creme
eigentlich schon fertig wir müssen sie
jetzt allerdings vollständig auskühlen
lassen
[Musik]
direkt auf dem pudding geben wir auch
noch frischhaltefolie damit sich keine
und schöne haut bildet während unser
pudding nun auskühlt machen wir weiter
mit dem frosting hierfür benötigen wir
zar peter kuvertüre sahne und butter
zu beginn werden butter und sahne im
kochtopf einmal unter ständigem rühren
aufgekocht
[Musik]
sobald das ganze dann hoch steigen will
nehmen wir das vom herd und gießen das
über die kleinen gehackte zar peter
kuvertüre
nun geben wir da einen deckel drüber
oder wie in meinem fall einem teller
hauptsache ist es luftdicht verschlossen
und es kann fünf minuten lang in der
hitze schmelzen
nach den fünf minuten rühren wir das gut
um bis sich alles verbunden hat und eine
einheitliche masse geworden ist danach
muss das ganze vollständig auskühlen am
allerbesten im kühlschrank und sobald
sie dann heruntergekühlt ist bekommt
eine richtig schöne konsistenz
und das war es auch schon mit der
vorbereitung jetzt fühle ich mir alle
beiden krems nur noch in meine
spritzbeutel und es geht ans dekorieren
jetzt nehme ich mir zuallererst die
mitte der cupcakes raus ihr könnt dafür
auch ein löffel nehmen oder das was ihr
gehabt da habt und spritze die boston
cream in die mitte
das ganze mit einem kleinen stück teig
verdecken und dann spritzen wir von
unserer leckeren schoko laden gersch
darüber und schaut mal wie schön
spritzig sie ist und das kriegt ihr hin
wenn sie im kühlschrank lagert
[Musik]
und so machen wir dann weiter bis ihr
sämtliche muffins befüllt und dekoriert
haben
[Musik]
ich verlinke euch gerne die stelle die
ich hier verwendet habe unten in die
infobox natürlich könnt ihr euer design
noch ganz anders spritzen macht am
besten das was ihr am nächsten mit und
fertig sind auch schon die boston queen
cupcake sie sind im kühlschrank
zugedeckt drei tage lang haltbar jedoch
bezweifle ich dass sie drei tage lang im
kühlschrank gelagert werden in diesem so
lecker schaut euch mal das innere an
ich könnte direkt schon wieder verlassen
ihr lieben falls ich euch jetzt auch
angesteckt habe mit meinem cupcake sie
war dann macht es gerne nach und schickt
mir eure kreationen auf instagram mit
dem hashtag ist kitchen und ich verlinke
euch selbstverständlich am ende des
videos noch meine anderen cupcakes es
werden noch ganz viele weitere folgen
und ich freue mich wenn ihr beim
nächsten mal auch wieder einschaltet